this is a second thought video made
possible by audible follow the URL or
use the SMS code in the description and
get a free audio book of your choice
when you sign up for a 30-day free trial
with audible the US military is really
good at spending huge sums of money on
expensive weapons with annual spending
usually fluctuating between 500 and 600
billion dollars and a requested several
billion dollar budget increase for 2018
there seems to be nothing too expensive
for the US military but what if they
wanted to expand beyond Earth if we've
learned anything about doing things in
outer space it's that it's very
expensive
what would it cost to build a
space-based super weapon like the Death
Star believe it or not a petition on We
the People to build a Death Star
actually gathered enough signatures to
merit official government response
unsurprisingly the US government didn't
think it was the best idea their
response was the administration does not
support blowing up planets and why would
we spend countless taxpayer dollars on a
Death Star with a fundamental flaw that
can be exploited by a one man starship
as silly as the petition was there
actually are estimates on how much it
would cost to build a Death Star in real
life sentence the student economics blog
at Lehigh University determined that it
would cost 852 quadrillion dollars just
to produce the steel required for
construction even without taking into
account the communications equipment
weapons personnel and day-to-day
operating costs of our hypothetical
Death Star that 850 quadrillion dollar
price tag is more than 13,000 times the
GDP of the entire world once you start
considering the full price things get
even more ridiculous a british energy
company crunched the numbers and the
cost of operating a Death Star is truly
absurd after the upfront cost of
constructing the base the daily cost to
keep it running would be an unbelievable
7.8 octillion dollars that's more than a
hundred trillion times the annual
economic activity of the entire planet
it's hard to fathom that huge of a sum
but when you break down everything that
goes into running a space station of
that magnitude it starts to make sense
the first Death Star depicted in Star
Wars Episode four is said to have been
between 100 and 140 kilometers in
diameter crewed by 1.7 million military
personnel four
maintenance droids and 250,000 civilians
and independent contractors assuming you
don't have to pay the droids or the
civilians and assuming you could get
away with paying everyone the same low
rate of say $10 an hour
paying your staff alone would set you
back over 32 trillion dollars per year
almost twice the annual GDP of the
United States lighting the whole space
station would cost fifty two billion
dollars per day and every single load of
laundry would cost two hundred million
then there's waste disposal feeding your
crew fueling fighters faster than light
travel and of course powering the giant
laser which would cost the reasonable
sum of eight octillion dollars per use
assuming you didn't fire the laser very
often that brings us to the daily
operating cost of 7.8 octillion dollars
okay so it's pretty reasonable to assume
we won't be building a Death Star any
time soon but will it ever be possible
in the future well probably not while
earth does have plenty of iron to
produce the steel required to build a
Death Star enough to build two million
of them in fact the problem is that this
iron is mostly located in the Earth's
core which would be hugely difficult and
dangerous to remove assuming we ever
figure out how to do it if we did manage
to get enough iron on the surface at
today's rate of steel production it
would take over 800,000 years to produce
the required amount of steel just to
build the shell of the Death Star then
to launch all that steel into orbit at
the current cost of $20,000 per kilogram
you're looking at over 21 quintillion
dollars before you can even begin
assembly the more cost-effective option
would be to mine the required resources
from asteroids or moons near the
construction site of course this would
still be prohibitively expensive for a
one planet species like us even for the
empire building a Death Star would have
been hugely expensive according to one
Star Wars expert at its peak the Empire
controlled one and a half million Core
Worlds and 69 million colonies all
linked together by a single economy so
if we want to build a Death Star we have
a little bit of work to do and if we
ever do build one maybe we'll learn from
history and not put a conveniently sized
thermal exhaust port anywhere on it now
that you've got star wars on the brain
why not download one of any of the tons
of Star Wars books on audible completely
free audible helps you listen to more
books by letting you switch seamlessly
between devices picking up exactly where
you left off whether it's on your phone
through your car from a tablet or at
home on an Amazon echo you can get
through tons of books while doing almost
anything
audible members get a credit every month
good for any audiobook you guard --less
of price and unused credits roll over to
the next month didn't like your
audiobook you can exchange it no
questions asked plus your books are
yours to keep with audible you can go
back and re-listen anytime even if you
cancel your membership start a 30-day
trial and your first audio book is free
sign up at audible.com slash second
thought or text second thought - 500 500
if you enjoyed this video make sure to
subscribe and click the little bell to
be notified every time a new second
thought video is released while you're
here check out these playlists full of
other great content thanks for watching
and we'll see you next week
[Music]